today we're talking about the
complicated issues of getting enough
sleep and i know so many people watching
right now
if you're kind enough to join us maybe
you can relate
i can joining us is sleep expert
dr thanusha hamilton dr hamilton
you say that getting a good night's
sleep um starts
before our heads hit the pillow at night
can you explain that
yes you can sleep better if you start
your day off right so one of the
important things
is getting sunlight sunlight actually
helps keep our circadian rhythm or our
internal clock in sync
it also boosts our energy for the day
which helps throughout the day and it
improves our mood
you know if you're not getting sunlight
that increases the risk of seasonal
affective disorder or the winter blues
which you can get in the summer by the
way if you're not getting outdoors and
getting sunlight
then you touched on something very
important activity
you know the homeostatic sleep drive or
the drive to sleep
increases the more energy you expend and
the more active you are
so absolutely get active um get out
there
and expend energy so that you sleep
better at night
uh the other thing is you want to avoid
taking long naps because that takes away
from the drive
to sleep and then of course avoid
significant amounts of caffeine
alcohol sugar all those things can
affect your sleep as i
down my iced tea i would take it
intravenously if i could
okay um we have a few tired vffs with
their sleep questions
hi amanda are you there hi drew
hi i'm landa hi okay what's your
question
so um ever since i started working from
home
i've had trouble sleeping i'm not sure
why the workload
has been the same i don't commute
anymore so
life has been a little less stressful i
just don't know why
i can't sleep dr hamilton
you know our workspace has changed uh
now you've got
kids homeschooling in the kitchen the
bedroom has become the office the
boardroom
the lunchroom there are people who are
in their pajamas all day so it's
really important to set bedtime bedroom
boundaries
only sleeping and sex in the bed
and if they're not happening within 15
minutes of being in the bed
you really have no business being in
there it's conditioning the bed to be a
place of sleep you can say your doctor
told you that
how's that work for you amanda sleeping
sex in the bed that's it
that's right take that advice
god and also make your bed every morning
because there's nothing more inviting
than walking into your room and seeing a
well-made bed
so make sure you do that every morning
we'll do doc
um okay next we have charlene uh you
have a question hi charlene
drew how are you good thanks
um you have a question for dr
hamilton right you're having some
trouble sleeping yes and that's been an
ongoing problem for a long time
i feel like no matter how tired i am
when i actually go upstairs to go to
sleep i can barely keep my eyes open
the minute my head hits the pillow i
start thinking of all the things i have
to do
my to-do list for the next day's
thoughts every anxiety or worry i have
and then suddenly i'm wide awake and
can't seem to shut my mind off to get
some rest i just kind of like to be able
to power down
even when i'm sleeping i feel like i'm
still thinking and i
kind of wish i could shut that off oh
dr hamilton what do you think so you
want to actually dedicate time a couple
of hours
before bedtime for those thoughts so for
15 minutes and not right
before bedtime because you don't want to
be fresh but a couple of hours before
set aside 15 minutes to write you can
write about what you thought about last
night what you might potentially think
about tonight
it could be whatever thoughts are coming
to your head but you
end up taking some of the steam out of
the thoughts in your head
and you put them on paper it could be a
to-do list a gripe list a gratitude list
whatever it is it actually helps
organize the thoughts of your head
and can be very good regardless of sleep
it can be good for you in general
do you think um because dr hamilton
suggested a to-do list
could you do a to-do list which would
prove you done
a bunch of stuff and you got to stop
obsessing about it check check check
and also a still need to do and then
you know for the next day because once
it's nighttime my
guru nancy drone and fallon because i
had the same problem i just couldn't
stop obsessing and she's like there's
nothing more you can do today and you
need
to tell yourself that um and so at
still to-do list and then you've got it
organized and you can let go
knowing that you've got the list and
you're not going to forget these things
i like the idea of
saying that there's not anything else
you can do for the day i think that's
really good advice too
i like that she changed my life when she
said that
because she i mean she even went on and
said there
no one's awake at this hour there's you
can't be prolific
you know the day is done for everybody
make a list of things
that you have left over and you attack
them tomorrow when the world is awake
again and functioning
right i like that um
dr hamilton i can't thank you enough
and it's been such an honor to talk
about a subject that really plagues
so many of us with someone who is um
as knowledgeable as you are oh
such a pleasure and you know sleep
really impacts
every aspect of your life and so i'm
glad that you're putting that value and
that importance
in sleep and sharing it with your
viewers well thanks to you we were able
to
all right thank you to all of our vffs
for sharing your life and experiences
with us and um dr hamilton you're the
best thank you
[Music]